bonsoir bienvenue pour ce journal de la
rédaction de tv 60,18 vous le voyez
plateau délocaliser ce soir au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
voici les titres de ce jeudi 27 février
l'enceinte sportive accueille la 3ème
édition de sky emploi en piste
l'événement recrutement de
l'agglomération sur place cinq mille
offres d'emploi 200 entreprises
représentées et des espaces dédiés
grande partie de cette édition consacrée
à l'événement et du sport également à
suivre avec du rugby féminin la ville de
plaisir recevez hier les finales inter
académique de la discipline cinq équipes
s'affrontaient sur le terrain et parmi
elles justement celle du lycée plaisir
roi jean vilar et puis suite et fin de
notre dossier de la rédaction sur les
femmes qui ont marqué l'histoire des
yvelines pour ce dernier focus est
découverte de marie aimée d'euros en
duchesse de chevreuse au xviie siècle
frondeuse elle était vue comme rebelle à
son époque portrait ch et nous parlerons
également enfin d'édition de la campagne
aux élections municipales
les deux sens
200 entreprises présentent cinq mille
offres à pourvoir le vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines avait
rendez vous avec l'emploi aujourd'hui
troisième édition de cet événement
proposé par l'agglomération sky emploi
en piste mathilde et demi et jacques
brun ont croisé ce matin la route de
quelques participants elles en ont
profité pour demander la raison de leur
présence ici écouter super bien présente
et en plus c'est super clair et il ya
pas mal de conseiller à olemps très
justement pour nous guider puisqu'il ya
pas mal d'offres et de propositions on
n'est pas perdu et le bien guidé en plus
il ya pas mal de conférences intéressant
donc ça c'est cool j'ai eu quelques
entretiens sur plusieurs stands
dont certains qui semble prometteur ça
s'annonce garde beaucoup d'offres
maintenant après il faut trouver le bon
partenaire on a dit bon employeur qui
fera qu'on sera à l'aise
le poste c'était très intéressant on a
pu échanger sur les attentes et les
besoins de la société et ce que je
pouvais moi leur apporter les rendez
vous sont offertes on arrive facilement
accéder aux employeurs enfin aux
employeurs aux cabinets de recrutement
assez facile d'avoir des contacts skype
lampiste qui se déroule au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
jusqu'à 19 heures et on parle de cet
événement avec mes deux invités jean
michel fourgous bonsoir président de
saint quentin en yvelines
erwan le gall bonsoir bonsoir conseiller
communautaire de l'agglomération délégué
à l'emploi et à l'insertion
professionnelle
l'an passé il y avait 3000 participants
qui avaient participé à forcément
participants participer à ce sky emploi
en pis 2500 entretien avait pu être
réalisée ce qu'on est dans les mêmes
clous que l'an dernier ce qu on a fait
plus aujourd'hui on est à peu près dans
les mêmes les mêmes résultats
à la seule différence par rapport aux
deux années précédentes c'est qu'on
monte et le témoignage de prouve aux
montants qualité c'est à dire que la
corrélation entre l'offre et la demande
est bien en phase
voilà donc qualité plus que quantité
mais qualité maîtrisée
jean michel fourgous troisième édition
de cet événement pourquoi pour une
agglomération c'est important on
rappelle l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien 16 mille
entreprises implantées sur le territoire
pourquoi c'est important pour saint
quentin en yvelines 2
d'être impliqué sur cette question de
l'insertion professionnelle parce que
saint quentin est une agglomération
quand même assez importante en france je
crois que vous savez en termes de pib
par habitant en aidant les premiers pib
donc bien sûr on a des entreprises d'un
service de qualité et qu'ils ont aussi
un niveau d'exigence
on le sent et bien entendu il se
retourne vers nous et je dis bon alors
il faut nous aider à trouver des talents
parce qu'une entreprise
le premier talent on achète d'entreprise
se souder les petits comme les gros
c'est le premier talent ces trous des
talents est en fait il se tourne vers
saint-quentin parce qu'on a une image
très entreprenariale la majorité de
l'équipe dirigeante vienne l'entreprise
et on sait ça et donc on est là pour
simplifier la vie nos entrepreneurs est
d aider à trouver les talents dont ils
ont besoin leur faire gagner du temps on
est des simplificateur il faut
simplifier la vie des entreprises il ya
beaucoup trop compliquée avec une
administration
aujourd'hui de plus en plus décalé par
rapport aux réalités de l'entreprise
donc on est là nous pour combler cet
écart
et en plus ils nous demandent même de
former parce que quand on ne trouve pas
eh bien on propose même de les former
donc oui et saint quentin
là tu vas loin d'autant plus qu'on
s'associe aujourd'hui complètement avec
paris saclay on est le coeur économique
de paris saclay je vous le rappelle est
donc il s'agit bien entendu d'activé
d'accélérer la formation de de certaines
pour certaines demandes des entreprises
par exemple
aujourd'hui on se rend bien compte qu'au
niveau du numérique je savais que 80%
des emplois de demain seront dans le
numérique façon seront associés au
numérique
donc il s'agit d' augmenter
l'employabilité numérique et là il ya
une forte demande des entreprises
entreprises bas alors alors alors j'ai
dit c'est du cash initiale mais dit oui
mais nous on s'en fou maintenant fait à
saint quentin
vous avez une image qu'on a c'est assez
entreprenariale donc aidez nous à
accélérer les formations donc on en est
à à bien sûr poser la question c est y a
pas que les ingénieurs bien sûr il ya
une très forte demande d'ingénieurs
parce qu'il ya un niveau celui-ci mais
il faut à tous les niveaux 1 jusqu'au
jusqu'au technicien il faut que nous on
puisse répondre donc on fait bien des
écoles d'ingénieurs on en a déjà pas mal
mais on va encore accélérer
bien sûr toutes ces formations qui sont
qui sont proches des ingénieurs d'un
système scolaire qui est extrêmement
scientifique aux techniques et numérique
vous le savez saint quentin un des
systèmes les plus innovants en matière
de culture scientifique et surtout on a
la première université scientifique et
paris saclay nous voilà tous les
ingrédients se chaînage est là et on est
là pour l'accélérer et simplifié et bien
sûr permettre à nos demandeurs d'emploi
ou à ceux qui veulent sur le convertir
lui un peu il ya 2 il ya deux catégories
ci assez clair c'est d'aller vite de
rencontrer des rages très vite de
comprendre les attentes de l'entreprise
très vite voilà on est là on est des
accélérateurs et puis surtout la qualité
comme l'a dit le n 2 se sont très bien
on a augmenté la qualification du rendez
vous est ce qu'elles sont faciles à
convaincre il est facile de convaincre
ces entreprises de participer à cet
événement 200 entreprises aujourd'hui
présentes
oui vraiment il n'y a aucune difficulté
à vienne sur sur l'événement mais on
voit que ça bouge
d'une année sur l'autre par rapport à
eux leurs courants économiques
l'année dernière il y avait renault qui
avait beaucoup d'offres d'emploi sa
tradition pas présent pour les raisons
que l'on connaît
mais voilà c'est la vraie vie il ya ikea
qui est la satanée qu'il n'est pas
l'année dernière mais oui il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de demandes
après ce qui est rassurant aussi céder
les pme qui ne viennent plus ça veut
dire qu'ils ont pourvu leurs offres
l'année de l'année précédente donc ça
c'est plutôt bonne chose il ya besoin de
jouer ce rôle de lien entre ces
entreprises justement qu'ils ont
peut-être des difficultés à recruter on
posera la question tout à l'heure à ikea
plaisir justement est aussi les
demandeurs d'emploi il faut faciliter
les rencontres
je vais pas reprendre les propos du
président mais il a très bien synthétisé
c'est à dire qu'on est en école un
poumon économique très fort très
puissant pour qu'une entreprise se
développe il ya plein de choses à mettre
en place une fois qu'elle se développe
elle a besoin de salariés et de
collaborateurs si nous on s'arrête au
moment du développement propre de
l'entreprise mais pas de l'autre face du
recrutement bien on n'a pas répondu à la
demande
entièrement beaucoup ici incontournable
une dernière question puisqu'on arrive
déjà bientôt à la fin de cet entretien
c'est un vélodrome qui est divisé en
cinq espaces cessation présente
l'événement cinq espaces dédiés pour
pour cet événement oui alors les espaces
ont été importants alors moi je suis pas
très bien placé pour en parler parce que
je pense qu'il faudrait demander aux
participants
mais c'est vrai que le booster le point
cv la cvthèque le point de relaxation
mais surtout moi ce qui compte ce que
j'ai retenu d'aujourd'hui de toute la
journée je vais passer auprès des chefs
d'entreprise
c'est le job dating a très bien
fonctionné et on a un peu réduit pour
qu'il y ait une puissance qui est qui
s'est imposée et on l'a vu et surtout
lorsque je suis passé sur tous les
stands tous une amie unanimement dits
c'était une très bonne qualité
la troisième édition est exceptionnelle
et à chaque fois que je suis resté 20 à
25 minutes à discuter avec les
recruteurs il y avait du monde qui
faisait la queue donc c'est je crois que
c'est la clé voilà et on le rappelle
cette édition du sky emploi en piste et
se déroule pardon jusqu'au jusqu'à 19h
au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines merci jean
michel fourgous merci à roanne le gall
d'avoir participé à ce plateau jean
michel fourgous président de saint
quentin en yvelines à roanne le gall
conseiller communautaire de
l'agglomération délégué à l'emploi et à
l'insertion professionnelle
et on en parlait justement pour ce sky
emploi en piste on trouve des espaces
dédiés notamment un showroom au centre
de ce vélodrome nationale vous y trouvez
des stands avec différents domaines
comme l'industrie le service à la
personne ou encore le bâtiment à de
nombreuses offres étaient proposés des
échanges se faisaient entre recruteurs
et demandeurs d'emploi mathilde et demi
plus de 200 entreprises sont réunis au
sky emploi l'espace showroom rassemble
les recruteurs sur des stands pour
échanger avec les demandeurs d'emploi
dans le secteur de la restauration le
stand elior est à la recherche
d'employés de service mais aussi de
pâtissier et de cuisinier il ya de la
demande
effectivement maintenant on se trouve
aussi face à une pénurie de postes
le chômage a pas mal régressé sur le
département du 78 de fait il ya pas mal
de gens qui sont en poste et ben il y en
a plus énormément qui sont disponibles
dans l'allée du service à la personne
on trouve le stand petit fils qui
recrutent 10 postes en cdi pour leur
nouvelle agence à voisins le bretonneux
pour accompagner les personnes âgées à
leur domicile
je petit fils on recrute des auxiliaires
de vie qui sont toutes des
professionnels qualifiés donc on recrute
des personnes qui ont un diplôme dans le
secteur médico social avec au minimum 3
années d'expérience auprès des personnes
âgées
notre principal autre critère de
recrutement étant le fait de pouvoir se
dire bah cette auxiliaire de vie ch
pourrait l'envoyer chez mes propres
grands parents le secteur de l'industrie
du bâtiment de l'immobilier bien
d'autres propose de nombreuses offres
il y a quelques années mayra rocher
faisait partie des demandeurs d'emploi
sur le salon aujourd'hui elle recrute
pour le stand century 21
j'étais venu sur le salon et puis on a
échangé on a discuté et finalement comme
j'étais
je cherchais un poste en alternance
parce que j'étais je faisais une licence
à dans l'immobilier du coup elle m'a
proposé de la rencontrer pour faire un
entretien d'embauché
pendant cette journée de recrutement
l'espace showroom situé au centre de la
piste du vélodrome présenter des offres
d'emploi sur saint quentin en yvelines
les recruteurs ont désormais toutes les
cartes en main pour recontacter des
demandeurs d'emploi qui ont déposé leur
cv 200 entreprises présentes dans ce
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour la troisième édition de
sky emploi en piste c'est un événement
également important de leur côté car
elles peuvent à ces entreprises exprimé
des difficultés à recruter écouter ses
propos collecter ce matin par nicolas
landry et patrick jacques de dixmude le
scandale quelques parcs voilà
aujourd'hui en ile-de-france mm à saint
quentin en yvelines c'est d'avoir des
emplois non pourvus
c'est un frein pour le développement des
entreprises et donc naturellement les
entreprises aussi ont besoin de recruter
et ont parfois du mal à recruter dans
des filières qui sont en tension sur
lesquels il ya une difficulté de
formation mais aussi sur des filières où
on a du mal à trouver les bons candidats
on connaît tous ici 50 a en tout cas les
élus des entreprises
condé dit finissent par avoir des
difficultés qui n'arrive plus à gagner
des marchés qui n'arrive plus à
remporter des appels d'offres faute
d'avoir les équipes suffisamment
d'équipés des équipes suffisamment
dimensionnés en nombre suffisant tout
simplement pour pour pour être
compétitif sur ces marchés
et parmi ces entreprises le groupe ikea
implantée à saint quentin en yvelines le
siège d'ikea est implantée à saint
quentin en yvelines sur la commune de
plaisir tout comme un magasin de
l'enseignent qui se situe dans la zone
commerciale plaisir oise
jenny est dû aux bons soirs ça alors
vous êtes people and culture
généralistes pour ikea plaisir déjà
people1 culture générale c'est le
nouveau nom pour désigner les ressources
humaines c'est ça responsables en
ressources humaines exactement voilà en
fait on a vraiment voulu assemblée donc
ces deux termes people et culture people
forcément pour retrouver le côté
ressources humaines et culture parce que
bas comme vous le savez certainement ica
est une entreprise suédoise a une qui a
une valeur qui a une qui a une culture
très forte et une très belle culture
donc voilà c'est vraiment en tant que
ressource humaine personnelle ressources
humaines on est les ambassadeurs de
cette culture première participation
à cet événement pourriture première est
vraiment très très satisfait de cette
première édition donc voilà j'ai compris
que c'était la troisième édition notre
première participation surtout dans ce
vélodrome c'était vraiment un super
cadre et on a passé une journée une très
bonne journée une journée active donc le
premier bilan il est positif à battre
est positif qu'est ce que vous avez fait
aujourd'hui combien de personnes
rencontrées sur place
alors ça a été vraiment très vite on
était 2 avec avec ma collègue charlotte
je pense que à peu près au un peu plus
d'une centaine de personnes et donc des
entretiens des entretiens qui pourrait
déboucher sur sur du positif et sûr
qu'elle de type d'offre que qu'est-ce
que vous avez proposé aujourd'hui
alors donc nous recherchions des postes
en logistique nous recherchions des
postes de vendeurs aussi également en
restauration puisque voilà certaines
personnes aujourd'hui était un petit peu
surprise de savoir que iker recruté en
restaurant puisque chaque magasin est
clair un restaurant et nous recherchons
aussi également à l'espace relation
client donc là c'est plutôt au niveau
des caisses si on revient aux origines
de la participation 10 cas pourquoi
avoir participé justement à cet
événement le sky emploi en piste alors
pourquoi déjà parce que nous avons des
besoins en recrutement on a des
difficultés pour recruter sur certains
métiers notamment la logistique mais
aussi en restauration sur les métiers de
production
donc pour nous c'était vraiment un moyen
d'aller à la un moyen facile d'aller à
l'encontre des personnes en recherche
d'emploi donc déjà d'une part et
deuxième chose aussi c'est important
pour nous de rencontrer également les
autres partenaires les autres acteurs
économiques de la belle région de notre
belle région
donc voilà c'est aussi l'occasion
d'échanger c'est toujours plus agréable
de mettre un visage sur un nom un numéro
de téléphone ou une adresse mail pour
voilà voir ensuite ce qu'on pourrait
mettre en place pour pour pallier aux
nous à nos besoins de recrutement est
trouvé
un métier un travail aux personnes en
recherche ça c'est intéressant d'avoir
alors aujourd'hui pour pour ce cas du ce
les ampoules à en pis c'est
l'agglomération qui fait le lien entre
les entreprises et les demandeurs
d'emploi c'est important qu'ils aient
cet intermédiaire pour faciliter les
rencontres
bah vous l'avez dit c'est c'est plus
facile c'est plus facile nous on peut
mettre en place des actions mais
forcément quand on est chez ikea on
allait on a une valeur qui est très
forte c'est ensemble et voilà c'est je
pense qu'on est convaincu que voilà
c'est avec l'aide de chacun les
compétences de chacun donc les pôles
emploi les plis les autres aussi les
autres aussi entreprises de la grande
zone commerciale où ikea est implanté
qu'on pourrai je trouve je pense trouver
ce qu'ils aiment et oui des profils
intéressants on l'a compris mais les
mots de la bouche
merci génie pillot qui peut aller une
culture généraliste à ikea plaisir merci
d'avoir participé à cette émission
voilà pour cette page dédiée aux sky
emploi en piste c'est je le rappelle
jusqu'à 19h au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines avec cinq
espaces dédiés on en parlait tout à
l'heure ce cas il recrute un job dating
géant le showroom pour découvrir lé
métier échanger directement avec les
entreprises à nîmes emploi coin des
ateliers conférences témoignages où nous
sommes justement en ce moment pour ce
journal booster pour préparer valoriser
votre candidature enfin un espace
bien-être pour s'orienter pour
rechercher son emploi en étant et zen je
précise d'ailleurs que le prochain
numéro de mode d'emploi sera consacrée à
cet événement en tv 78 émis pour
l'occasion dans la peau d'un demandeur
d'emploi mode d'emploi retrouver
justement demain à vendredi sur tv 78
le reste de le reste de l'actualité
locale avec d'abord du sport les finale
interacadémique de rugby féminin se sont
déroulées hier sur le terrain de plaisir
cinq équipes se sont affrontées et parmi
elles les lycéennes plaisir oise de jean
vilar c'était une première ambiance avec
aurélie rond et marylène yapi chinois
elles ont entre 15 et 17 ans et sont 10
à défendre les couleurs de lycée jean
vilar à plaisir pour cette finale deux
académies sont représentés versailles et
créteil sur les cinq équipes en lice
seules deux pourront se qualifier aux
championnats de france
on se bat on donne tout ce qu'on a sur
certains matches à quelques erreurs mais
bon après on est là pour s'améliorer
aussi l'association sportive de rugby
féminin a été créé il ya seulement
quelques mois au lycée jean vilar
les joueuses s'entraînent une fois par
semaine cet événement permet notamment
de mettre en valeur ce sport qui se
développe de plus en plus chez les
femmes
mes filles vont moins vite c'est moins
impressionnant en termes de vitesse de
jeu par contre c'est un rugby où il ya
beaucoup plus de continuité le ballon à
la vie bien les filles arrivent à
vraiment mettre pas mal de pas mal de
rythme et de continuité dans le jeu dont
c'est un rugby qui est agréable à
regarder
c'est en même temps aussi une ambiance
au sein de l'équipe qui est vraiment
chouette
on se soude on est vraiment on se parle
beaucoup et on se motive les uns les
autres et vraiment c'est ça qui nous
fait se motiver on sait que nos amis qui
sont dans les gradins notre famille des
fois aussi des professeurs des les
surveillantes c'est important pour elle
c'est important pour l'établissement de
vivre une expérience riche et j'espère
qu'ils ne feront que ne font que débuter
qu'on ira beaucoup plus loin les années
prochaines
les filles du lycée jean vilar termine
sur la deuxième marche du podium
l'île de france sera représentée par
deux lycées de l'académie de créteil au
championnat de france
clap de fin pour notre dossier de la
rédaction de février toute cette semaine
tv 60,18 vous faisait découvrir le
parcours de femmes qui ont marqué
l'histoire des yvelines elle était
considérée comme l'une des plus belles
femmes de son époque elle marie aimée
d'euros en duchesse de chevreuse avait
usé de ses atouts pour ses stratégies
politiques frondeuse de la première
heure est louis xiii l'a même qualifié
de diable sur son lit de mort portrait
de cette femme rebelle du xviie siècle
avec marylène ya piché nord dans le
château de dampierre aujourd'hui vide
pour travaux se trouvait une duchesse
voilà où son visage est toujours présent
sur les murs au dessus d'une porte le
portrait de marie aimée d'euros en
duchesse de chevreuse que seul un
historien averti peut reconnaître
né avec son siècle en 1600 marie-aimée
dort on arrive à ses 17 ans à la cour de
louis xiii et d'anne d'autriche où elle
fait sensation
à 18 ans elle était sur un temps tante
d'anne d'autriche
pour vous donner une idée l'importance
du poste de surintendant qu elle
commandait environ 600 personnes
inutile de vous dire qu'elle faisait des
envieux et ce qu'elle avait à l'a20
privilège qui était très couru chez les
grandes dames et des grandes familles
c'est qu'elle avait ce qu'on appelle le
droit du tabouret ou du carreau c'est à
dire que c'était seuls ces princesses de
grands noms avaient le encore un
privilège de pouvoir s'asseoir en
présence de la famille royale et ces
dames se battait pour avoir le privilège
du carreau ou du tabouret la reine de
france restera son ami il viendra même
la visite et à dampierre le château dans
lequel elle passera du temps avec son
second mariage avec claude de lorraine
mais marie deroo ont été surtout une
femme qui plaisait aux hommes ce qu'il
faut savoir à en regardant ses yeux qui
sont quand même extrêmement évocateur
c'est richelieu qu'il l'avait surnommée
la chevrette
c'était bien normal puisqu'elle était
duchesse de cheuvreux elle était réputée
très délurée très coquine très
intelligente très belle et donc on l'a
ici on voit bien qu alain lanty côté
j'allais dire sarcastique c'est pas tout
à fait de qualificatifs mon sens que l
un regard qui vous fouilles de
l'angleterre à l'espagne tout ce qu'on a
ses charmes ton assez habilement joué
depuis son hôtel de chevreuse rue saint
thomas du louvre à paris
c'était complètement une femme politique
c'est à dire que les ministres les deux
ministres successifs les deux cardinaux
successifs s'en référer à ce sont
couronne penser on l'aménagé on l'a on
la questionner particulièrement stratège
la duchesse s'attirer les foudres des
puissants qui n'hésitait pas à l'envoyer
régulièrement en exil 12 ans de sa vie
cumulés certains de ces exils consistait
à rester au château de dampierre dans
lequel elle n'était pas enfermé bien mis
ton elle partait par la porte rouge qui
se trouvait derrière ces pavillons elle
se déguise en homme
elle prenait son cheval elle allait à
paris retrouvé tous ses bons copains
ni vu ni connu alors on dirait matin le
faisait une belle java et puis ont
fomenté des révoltes on préparait on
astique authentic on faisait monter la
mayonnaise passe de révolte enfin monde
une révolte qui porte un nom la fronde
marie aimée de rouen il sera au coeur
avec la duchesse de longueville pour
défendre leurs privilèges face à la
monarchie goûterait dira d'elle que
cette femme est le diable une femme qui
quittera ce monde avec panache faisant
parvenir ou à louis xiv une lettre et
sir il me sera beaucoup pardonné car
j'ai beaucoup aimé ainsi l'âge venu la
sagesse apparu s'est retiré des rondes
que j'écris pour ma tombe ces quelques
qu'elle graf en guise d'épitaphe ci gît
dans une paix profonde une dame de
volupté qui pour plus de sécurité prie
le paradis dans ce monde en restant en
vallée de chevreuse avec cette balade à
moto sur les routes du sud yvelines 34
membres du bmw motorrad club france se
sont retrouvés le week-end dernier à
rambouillet un parcours reliant la ville
à montfort l'amaury michael et demi
d'euros les a rencontrés juste avant
leur départ
c'est le paradis des motards mais il ya
des jolies petites routes qui tourne
il ya des jolis paysages donc voilà il
ya tout ce qu'il faut pour qu'on pour
qu'on soit heureux pour trucs pour peu
qu'on ait un peu de soleil alors c'est
plus motivant parce qu'on n'est pas
toujours sûr d'avoir une météo très
agréable donc ça permet de se motiver
ça permet de passer des moments de
rigoler et puis c'est toujours plus
intéressant de rouler en groupe et de
voir les virages s'enchaînent et sur les
petites routes
cette information pour les jeunes de 15
à 17 ans habitant anguilles en cours la
municipalité propose cet été de
participer à un séjour interculturel a
comme et au bénin une ville jumelée avec
lui en cours au programme de ce voyage
qui se déroulera dans la première
quinzaine de juillet visite échanges et
rencontres autour de la citoyenneté
immersion dans la vie quotidienne des
jeunes béninois nombre de places limité
à douze tarif de 180 euros les
inscriptions sont ouvertes jusqu'au 31
mars
mais nous refermons justement ce journal
à guyancourt avec un mot des élections
municipales premier tour pour rappel le
15 mars prochain comme ailleurs la
question de la transition écologique
s'est invitée au coeur de la campagne
un débat entre les candidats étaient
organisées hier soir mercredi par le
collectif guyancourt toit pour le climat
une soirée des changes suivi par mélanie
poké quatre thématiques principales les
têtes de listes guyancourt toise ou
leurs colistiers présenté à des
habitants leur programme notre programme
c'est pas une série de mesures que l'on
vérifie six ans après qu'on a fait mais
que l'on est vraiment dans un système
c'est à dire par exemple si on met de
l'agriculture sur les terrains de la
minière c'est aussi pour faire du lien
social c'est aussi pour faire de la
pédagogie vis-à-vis des écoles c'est
aussi pour alimenter une cantine et
c'est aussi pour créer des emplois sert
bouclé toutes les pistes on a des pistes
qui sont
les quartiers ne se joignent pas il n'y
a pas de jointure entre les quartiers on
a des pistes qui sont en piteux état il
faut les reconstruire il faut les
sécuriser il faut les aménager et il
faut permettre à nos habitants de
circuler d'avoir des promesses des
commerces de proximité pour pouvoir y
aller à pied
voilà s'étonne tout un tout aménagé 15
minutes pour convaincre après un tirage
au sort sur la question politique
alimentaire l'équipe de philippe paris
souhaite notamment installer une cuisine
centrale il décède au delà de la mettre
en même temps face à conti en même temps
que le nouveau centre technique
municipal
et puis 10 mètres d'une personne
professionnelle aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de personnel professionnel de la cuisine
à la mairie après il y aura deux
possibilités c'est quelque chose qu'on
étudie encore c'est soit la voir en
régisseur nous-mêmes ou soit
externaliser la prestation la nourriture
bio ou labellisés bio les circuits
courts en priorité et puis le travail
sur le non gaspillage également sur la
question de la construction le maire
sortant françois morton a souhaité
mettre en avant l'idée d'une mixité une
construction en soi n'a pas de sens si
on ne met pas ce qu'il ya derrière c'est
à dire des êtres humains notamment dans
le cadre de leur logement
il s'agit alors d'habitat ou de leur
travail et on peut parler à ce moment-là
de développement économique ou de
services aux habitants au travers des
services publics donc on ne construit
pas un bâtiment pour construire un
bâtiment il a forcément une fonction le
public a ensuite pu poser des questions
qui étude sur les étangs la minière
traque de transition ou encore
démocratie participative à l'origine du
débat le collectif guyancourt toit pour
le climat aujourd'hui il ya un problème
au niveau de
de l'environnement de la pollution du
réchauffement climatique ce sont des
thématiques ont pas été prise
suffisamment au sérieux dans le passé
dans le récent passé aujourd'hui il est
absolument indispensable de mettre
l'accent sur ces sur ces sujets et qu'il
y ait des actions qui soient efficaces
pour lutter contre ces problèmes
un absent pour cette soirée ma belle à
des kew que tête de liste union des
démocrates musulmans français excusé
pour des raisons de santé
une centaine de personnes a assisté à la
soirée c'est la fin de ce journal depuis
le vélodrome nationale à l'occasion de
sky emploi en pis retour dans les
studios de tv soixante dix huit avec
dans un instant le 7-8 loisirs belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]